what's up marvel fans we're here with
willem dafoe who plays green goblin all
right what was your reaction when you
were told the premise of this film
uh sounded good good enough to sign on
in order to revisit this character
now what was it like revisiting that
character how was that it was great i
mean it's uh
yeah it's a continuation and uh this is
probably the most ambitious film in this
series so far
so it's great to be a part of it
see some old friends see some new
friends you know
that's incredible what was it like
working with director john watson the
awesome ensemble he was great i mean uh
you know they had a lot of people had
worked together before so they were
really at good chemistry already a lot
of trust and
yeah it was it was fun to work uh
you know very loose but also uh you know
we were we were making our days and
having fun
do you have a favorite spider-man moment
in the mcu
oh god that's that's a tough one yeah
too hard again yeah there's so many i
you know i enjoy doing the action stuff
[Music]
you